Speaker 1: One little final follow up from the
weekend's CPAC. This is Sarah Palin. Sarah Palin
is fascinating. We have covered Sarah Palin
for a really long time because back in 2008,
she was the late Senator John McCain's vice
presidential running mate. And at the time,
she became known to us for her incomparable words,
salads and her abject failure at using language to
communicate. She just couldn't do it. She she you
saw her mouth moving. You heard things coming out.
Some of them were words, but it didn't fit
together in any way that made sense. It's sort
of like if you made a dish for dinner and like you
see a plate and you're aware that there's pasta
in the toilet and you saw tomato sauce on top of
the fridge, like individually, these are elements
of food, but it's not coming together in any way
that makes sense. Now. Similarly, when Sarah Palin
appeared at CPAC over the weekend, she was
apparently trying to quote Abraham Lincoln.
And she is so visibly confused and so incoherently
trying to use language that I don't know what
the hell she's talking about. It also looks
like she has a massive, gaudy star of David
hanging from her neck. I mean, every aspect of
this is whacked, and whatever is going on with
her seems to be getting worse and worse.
Maybe she was referring to a Lincoln log.
I don't know. But this doesn't sound like
anything I've ever heard Lincoln say.
Speaker 3: It is. And what they're doing
is usurping that the power from the other
two branches of government, the judiciary and
the legislative branch, we can't allow that to
happen. Things like that, that that create this
atrophy in the foundation of America will destroy
America. It's like Lincoln said, we're not going
to be destroyed from foreign forces coming on in.
It's going to be from within. If we allow
things that are so anti-constitutional to
to be able to usurp, for instance, the balance
of power. So, yes, Dan Sullivan is right.
Speaker 1: You know, is she talking about
Abraham Lincoln? Because don't what she
she said it's like Lincoln said, look, let's
really acknowledge it's like Lincoln said,
we're not. Going to be destroyed from forces
coming on in. It's going to be from within if we
allow things that are so anti-constitutional to be
able to, for instance, usurp the balance of power.
I guess she means we must protect ourselves from
domestic threats more than foreign threats. Is
that. Am I incessantly summarizing what she meant
there? I don't know. I genuinely don't know.
But Sarah Palin continuing to visibly struggle to
use the English English language to communicate.